the Memphis Police Department has fired
all five officers involved in the
traffic stop arrest that may have led to
the death of Tyree Nichols the
department said the five officers
violated its policies pertaining to use
of force duty to render Aid and duty to
intervene Memphis Police said on January
7 Nichols tried to run away on foot
after officers pulled him over for
reckless driving when he was eventually
caught and arrested he complained of
shortness of breath the 29 year old died
three days later in the hospital his
family claims he was brutally beaten the
police department said it will release
the arrest footage next week the FBI and
justice department are also launching an
investigation into Nichols death